All right, welcome back to the program.
We sadly and tragically had a guest, no call,
no show on us last minute, but it's a great
opportunity since we missed live calls last
week because of the election and the craziness
to hear from a few folks through the discord
at David Pakman dotcom slash discord, let's
first go to Laura from Richmond.
Laura from Richmond.
You were on.
What's on your mind today, Laura?
Oh, boy, hold on one second, Laura.
We have we don't have things properly cued
in.
I can hear you, but just bear with me just
just one moment and we're going to be your
audio is coming out of a very, very strange
place and we need it coming out of a normal
voice.
OK, Laura, you were I can now hear you in
the right spot.
Awesome.
Well, today's my birthday.
Happy birthday.
Thank you.
I just wanted to say that I watched your live
stream of the vice presidential debate and
also Comilla and Biden's acceptance speeches.
And it was it was a great experience.
Thank you.
Thank you for doing that for us.
Thank you for watching it.
So my question today revolves around the 25th
Amendment right.
I haven't really heard a lot about that lately,
but it seems like the more Trump seems to
be getting unhinged.
Yeah.
Would it be something that would be the proper
thing to do for the vice president, who I
haven't heard a thing from, by the way?
Well, he went on vacation this week.
Pence went on vacation to Florida this week
of no.
You bring up a good question.
So there's two questions.
Would it be appropriate to remove Trump via
the 25th Amendment?
Of course it would, and it would have been
appropriate years ago.
Is it going to happen in the last nine weeks
or however many weeks he has of his presidency?
It's not because it depends on his cabinet
and the vice president, and they're not going
to do it.
So, yes, it would be appropriate.
No, it's not going to happen.
It just seems like I'm I'm afraid that he's
going to intentionally do something that harms
this country that will be very difficult to
recover from.
That's completely already.
Yeah, that's completely plausible.
But, you know, in being hyper realist, Trump's
cabinet is not removing him.
You know, Laura, that's the reality.
And we have to deal with the cards were dealt,
as they say.
Yeah, they paid for their positions.
They in a sense, they did.
And they are not going to remove this guy.
But listen, it's down to weeks.
You know, I guess that's what we have, try
to limit damage during the next few weeks.
Well, we've held on this long as we can hold
on a little bit longer.
Let's hope so.
That's my hope.
That's exactly my hope.
But thank you so much for taking my call.
My pleasure, Laura.
From Richmond, great to hear from you.